volkanowski was and is still arguably
Palm for pound greatest fighter in the
world how long have you known him I
don't know the first one I met him
before he was in the UFC when I used to
live in Melbourne he came down to train
it absolute yeah and then we really
connected on Ultimate Fighter he one of
his guys who's going to bring told him a
fighter barbadell pulled out last second
so he called me when I was in Puerto
Rico and he's like do you want to coach
on tough for five weeks and like I said
Puerto Rico was Apocalypse Now I was
like yeah get me out of here so I took
jumped on that opportunity and we were
in Vegas five weeks together because he
was meant to fight Ortega and then he
got hit with covert real bad
uh got stuck in I think he was in
hospital for maybe one to two weeks and
then before he flew back to Australia
they were like all right maybe we just
do you guys as The Ultimate Fighter
coaches so I jumped on board with that
and that's really when we've become
close yeah obviously I was useful in the
Ortega fight help him get out of
submissions
he fought then Korean Zombie Max
Holloway I basically just held the
bucket at that point in the corner a
couple striking uh fights and then again
yeah we had to tackle the Islam problem
so I did spend five to six weeks down
there preparing for that how did you uh
tackle the Islam problem
was you somebody who barely knows
anything about wrestling having to
obviously doesn't take much you know
yeah especially Russian wrestling uh did
the beard help or like what like in all
seriousness what were some of the key
ideas you that you worked on with
volcanovski to prepare for it I had the
help of Frank Hickman Hickman was down
there too one of the Hickman Brothers uh
wrestling coach so we were sort of like
problem solving and I mean basically we
were confident in Volks uh fence
wrestling his cage work he's super good
on the catch super like uh
under respected in that position and we
knew that if we were able to take the
scrambles to the cage he would be
effective against Islam because again
Islam is background of [__] Freestyle
Wrestling but I mean honestly he's
probably got the same experience on the
cages folks obviously some of those uh
wrestling skills would translate very
well to the cage but the cage is still
somewhat of a gray area an equalizer
involves again incredible ability to
stand up incredible defense on the cage
which you saw we worked on strategies to
get up and a ton of submission defense
Islam loves Kimora's obviously reenacted
from the back arm bars those are sort of
and Armstrong's dominant submissions but
again the guys he submitted
not grapples
apart from Charles Oliveira and again
Charles Oliveira was basically knocked
out at that point so I was still
impressed if he submitted him but again
I always told people this they thought
it was crazy I was like Charles Oliveira
versus Islam in a grappling match
Oliveira is going to win that match
like submission grappling submission
grappling yeah so if you were grappling
skill set I think Oliveira is a more
dangerous Grappler so we didn't even
come into it thinking Islam was this
Unstoppable Boogeyman that people make
him out to be
so we approached her from that just
focused on the techniques
ability to get back up using Turtle to
get back up using Turtle to scoot to the
cage to get back up and hand fighting
from there keeping it pretty safe but
what makes Volks so special I think is
his gas tank gas tank and his willpower
he's just unbreakable the dagestani guys
khabib Islam they are good at
submissions but okay they break guys
mentally and they fatigue him and then
they take the submission that's offered
Oliveira is a guy that can jump on
submissions and have an incredible
technical ability to finish those
submissions whether you're fresh or
you're tired and then you combine that
with falconowski who incredible
willpower never gets tired you're never
going to break him and as you saw he
only attempted one submission the whole
fire is that learned is that trained or
are you just born with that that mental
toughness it's a good question I mean
he's like an anomaly like the entire
fight Camp not nervous at all supremely
confident the whole fight week
completely confident he just has an
attitude like oh everyone cast me out
we'll see you know what I mean Islam
he's like let's see no doubt no doubt at
all super relaxed up until about five
minutes before and then he starts
stamping himself up he's like you are
not taking this belt from my family gets
into that sort of mindset he actually
says that out loud
you can't teach that survival he didn't
even take a fight you know
have you guys ever been like pushed to
the Limit like that or broken in a
grappling match
I'll do it in practice like I'll push
myself to like you know I think it might
pass out or die or something like as far
as like uh how tired you get you know
because like in a match
um they try not to ever get close to
that anymore yeah you try to because you
know it's important to understand uh
where you're exhausted exhaustion point
is
um but yeah if you have to push to that
limit imagine probably do doing
something wrong you know like if you
like you've seen matches where guys
Sprint the last like minute they're
trying to win the match in last minute
and it's like you definitely had some
mistakes leading up to that if you have
to you know gonna go boss the wall
okay but has there been other times in
competition especially like early on
because you're like you wrestled pretty
hard and wrestling is pretty exhausting
like not wrestling but you know
wrestling style kind of thing going
against the best people in the world
yeah I mean I definitely again I think I
think in practice it's important to uh
do that hard work that where competition
is is much easier you know I think if
you if you Redline in practice and you
really push through like death's door uh
then once you're in competition and
you're working with you know you're
being fresh in a compliment
it's much better have you ever been to
that thing where Dan Gable talks about
always wanting to be to a place where
you can't get off the mat
like you work so hard in the training
room you can't get off the mat I think
he says he's failed at that in his
career he was always able to at least
crawl off the mat
yeah I definitely never like actually
died on the map but I felt like I felt
like I was gonna die you know sure uh
what about you do quit all the time I
get a lot of cramp I'm like you know
what you got me man let's do this again
tomorrow
dude if I'm asking Craig for a role he's
in the bathroom somewhere
do you do you see the value of pushing
yourself like to that place where you're
knocking on dust storms yeah but within
safety you know because obviously the
most uh serious injuries occur when
you're tired of training and stuff like
that so I think like taking a page out
of what those MMA fighters do especially
Volks with his training like he's not
necessarily pushing crazy in each round
but he's doing extra conditioning
assault bike stuff crazy workouts
outside
and uh he does do some crazy training
workouts but all safe very safe like
when he's redlining like that in the
training room it's a very controlled
safe setting I think to do that in Jiu
Jitsu against some of these lunatics out
there that are trying to kill you
especially when you have a name can be
dangerous so your approach is just as
don't warm up and don't try too hard
no sir no for safety though yeah
longevity you know and talk [__] to
about Russians I got it I got it I hear
you oh you mentioned uh cage work what
what what's interesting to you that
you've learned overall this time about
cage work what's like what's interesting
about the Dynamics of that are you
talking about both like the control
in the dominant position but also
getting up from the bottom while you're
against the cage all of that the added
dimension of that cage that wool being
there changes a lot of stuff right so
obviously in some ways it's a much lower
Impact Wrestling style because he can't
be thrown on you can shoot the cage is
going to block their feet you're going
to be able to chase down their hips it's
just a completely different fight and
again because of Islam's Judo skills
that upper body controls you see he's
able to use against the cache like the
inside trips uh sort of the YouTube
artist style all right Goshi throws so
obviously those skills do translate but
yeah I think the cage is a great
equalizer for a lot of things like
athleticism and stuff it takes away a
huge speed Advantage uh aspect of the
fire so he's really good at staying up
what is is there I assume he learned all
that from you and your instructional
just stand up I mean we were so
confident I was like you know what why
don't we put this thing out a month
before the fun yeah maybe the illegal
download hasn't made its way to Russia
yet yeah but it was there for him can
you can you explain to me what's in the
instructional just stand up like what
what are what are the ideas what do you
I mean the old school way to stand up
people to talk about the technical get
up you know the old Gracie put the hand
but I mean that's that doesn't work
hasn't worked for 20 years you know if
you look at everyone that gets up in MMA
they're using Turtle to get up they're
using wrestling together you know what I
mean yeah which is uh counter to what
pure Jujitsu says they say don't expose
the back don't ever expose your back I
think Jiu Jitsu is a terrible way to get
back to the feet because if you were to
retain guard and go half got a close
guard super hard positions to get up
you're basically putting yourself in a
leg tuck for wrestling so I think you
need to borrow from wrestling to learn
how to get up in an MMA fighter so
basically how to safely expose your own
back while not allowing them to get
Hooks and use that to get back up or at
least not allow them to get two hooks
and that applies for MMA especially for
MMA especially because obviously uh
striking is a factor but if they are
striking they don't have locked hands
around your body means you are able to
move you are able to make an attempt to
get back up they have to choose between
control submission or strikes